で あの いろいろ因果法則の中でね
まあ原因・因縁っていうのはもう数えられないほどあるんですね
すべての現象は何かのものの因縁になります
ですから そういう意味でここで考えているわけじゃないんですね
どんな現象でもそれなくなると
またそれなりの違う現象の原因になってしまうんですね
そうするとすべてのものは原因にもなるし
結果でもあるんですね
でもこの場合はそういうことじゃなくて
この善と不善を決める
決定する原因 で 特に人間の生命の行為
行為というそのものは善行為か不善行為かと
決定する場合は使う印であって
それは貪瞋痴と無貪無瞋無痴と
で 貪瞋痴が心の中に入っているならば
その行為は不善であって
無貪無瞋無痴が入っているならば
その行為は善行為になるということ
で それから十六書いてるところでジャーナンガ
ジャーナンガ ジャーナっていうのは禅定であって禅であって
禅という禅定の状態の中にどういうどういうものが入っているかと
いわゆる禅定を得た禅定を体験する瞬間で
その心の状況で 全部じゃなくて特色な状況
普通の状況と付け加えて
こういうジャーナンガもありますと
それは七つあるんですね
その七つ まあ心所ですけどね
その七つの心所がいくらかあるならば
それはジャーナンガと呼ぶんです
それはヴィタッカ ヴィチャーラ
ピーティ エーカッガター
ソーマナッサ ドーマナッサ
ウペッカー ヴィタッカはこの
いわゆるまあ「陣」と書いてあって
まあいわゆる言葉 頭の中で使ってるという言葉なんですね
ことなんですね ヴィタッカっていうのは
で ヴィチャーラっていうのは言葉なくてもやっぱり物事を観察していられる状態
で ヴィタッカの場合は言葉をもって瞑想対象を観察しているんですね
ヴィチャーラの場合は言葉なくても観察し続けられるんですね
ですから ヴィタッカある場合はヴィチャーラもありますね
言葉をもって観察するときも
やっぱり観察しているんだから
ヴィタッカの次は必ずヴィチャーラあります
で ヴィチャーラがあるところで必ずヴィタッカがあるかというと
それはそうじゃないんですね
言葉なしに もう言葉抜けてでも観察することはできますからね
で 普通では最初はどんな瞑想
例えば言葉をもって瞑想し始めなくちゃいけないし
徐々に物事を明確に見えるようになってくると
まあ言葉は遅くなってしまってね
それより早く現象が生滅変化してきますので
言葉で確認するっていうこと
観察するっていうことはなかなか合わなくなっちゃいますね
スピードが そういうスピードが合わなくなる場合は
言葉を置いておいて観察し続けることはできるんです
ピーティっていうのは喜であって喜びなんですね
次にあるのは あの えーと
まあピーティっていうのは大変あの
強力な喜びなんですね
すごい力強い この まあ感激するような感じのね
喜びなんですね ピーティ
で エーカッガター 一境性
落ち着めてるんですね
心があちこち走らないで
一つのところに囚われてというか
まあ一つのものに集中していられる状態
それエーカッガター それからまたソーマナッサンという言葉が出てくるんですね
で ソーマナッサンという場合は
それほど力強い感激というものよりは
普通に喜びという楽しみという意味なんですね
それにドゥーマナッサスが入ってるんですね
ドゥーマナッサっていうのは憂いですな
悲しみじゃなくて 楽しみではなくて
なんとなく悲しみ 嫌という感じなんですね
それからそういう楽しみも悲しみもない
もう普通な状態をペッカーと言うんですね
で ここでこのテキストではね
そこら辺で説明は終わってますけど
で アビダンマ的には合わないんですね
言ってること で ジャーナっていうのは
禅というのはやっぱり確実に禅信であって
不善にはならないんです
で 不善心の中にドーマナッサ優遇の心は出てこないんですね
だから八十九種類の心の中で優遇というか
優遇相ですかね で 心は二つしかないんですね
その二つも深根心ですね
いわゆる怒りに基づいている心なんですね
今はこのドーマナッサという憂いということのことを説明しています
ですから あの怒りの心
二つはあります それはドーマナッサハガタンという優遇ですね
憂い で 禅といえば やっぱり色界の無色界の禅定ですからね
完全にそれは大心でもあるし
禅心でもありますし ですから禅定では憂いっていうのはありえないんです
そこでここでなんでそれを入れたかっていうことは説明しないんですね
他の六つはもう禅定の心にあるんですね
で こちらはこの最後の三種は十に入るから
持象として五善支に五善支となると
という説明ですけどね
まあいい加減といえばいい加減なんですね
で だからこのウェーダナーはね
どんな心にも十というウェーダナーがあるんですね
じゃあ十がなければ心が生まれませんだからね
ですからそれは七つの一切
あの表心所ですか 七つの一切心所に入ってるんですね
一番目はパッサ速であって
二番目は十なんですね
だから心所の勉強を始めたところで二番目に来たのは十なんですね
それが十というウェーダナーって
がどんな心にもあります
だから禅定の心にも必ずあります
だから受といえば三種類ですから
受といえばあの こういう楽
楽と苦と不苦不楽というかね
そういう三種類の受がありますからね
だからパーリ語で言えばソマナス
ドマナス ウペッカーというね
ソマナスは喜愚 ドマナスは憂愚と
それからウペッカーは捨愚ですね
ですから ただ受のことで密閉しているんだという意味でありまして
受といえば人しかないんですからね
本当は じゃあ次にあるのはマッガンガ
十七 だから道支と書いて
道といえばだいたい普通私たち知ってるのは八正道ですね
で なんで道というかというと
この悟りに導かれるという解脱に導かれるということでマッガというし
あるいは仏教では推薦している生き方として
人の道としてマッガという言葉を使っているんですね
いわゆるわざと実践しなくては
実行しなくては 成長しなくてはならないものはマッガガであって道支になるんですね
そこでミッツァカだから混ぜているんだから
やっぱり実践してはいけないものも入っているし
だから善も悪もごちゃ混ぜに入れるのはこのミッツァカサンガハなんですね
ですからこの善種の場合も
やっぱり禅定に入るものも
禅定に関係ないものも似ているんだから混ぜているんですね
でも善 善種といえばそれは合わないんだけどね
で 合わないんだけど やっぱり同じ働きだから
善も不善も一緒にまとめて入れる
で マッガという道の場合も
同じくいいもの悪いものもまとめているんです
ですから八正道の場合は八しかないんだけど
こちらは十二が出ていることですね
それはサンマディッティ
サンマサンカッパ サンマーワーチャー
サンマカーッマント サンマアジーバ
サンマワーヤマ サンマサティ
サンマサマーディ ミッチャーディッティ
ミッチャーサンカッパ
ミッチャーワーヤマ ミッチャーサマーディ
これ十二ではなくて十六にした方がいいな
とにかく十六にするとまたいろいろトラブルが起こる可能性もありますからね
まあとにかくこの人の実践
人の道という意味でマッガ
ですから この中に人が実践実行するべきものもあって
してはいけないものも入ってあって十二になる
最初の八は有名な八正道に入ってるんですね
正見というのは智慧のことであって
で 智慧のことなんですけど
だから智慧があれば全部そこで修行終わってしまいますけど
ですから修行中の人々も覚っていない人々の場合も
修行に仏道に励む場合はそれも正見と言うんですね
ですから正見はやっぱり二種類あるんです
一つは覚った人の正見と
もう一つは悟るために努力する人の正見
[12秒間拍手]それから正思惟というのはこの考えることなんですね
まあ思考のこと 考えること
ですから この瞑想にはかなりややこしい邪魔になりますが
考えることはね やっぱり邪魔になるといったっても
まあ生きているものの働きの一つなんですね
考えるということは ですから
考える場合はどうしても考えちゃいますから
じゃあ正思惟で考えてくださいということになっちゃうんですね
正しいことを考えなさいと
正しい考え方っていうのは三つありまして
ネッカンマ・サンカッパ
アヴィャーパーダ・サンカッパ
アヴィーヒンサー・サンカッパ
ネッカンマ・サンカッパっていうのは欲の反対的な考え方
普通の人々は欲に従って欲を増やすことはずっと時間考えてるんですね
で 心はそういう癖になってるんですね
自分のことを まあ自分のことばっかり考えてるんですね
やはりそれは欲の考え方なんですね
で それは普通なんですね
で なかなか人はこの出世的な
あるいは欲から離れる方向へ考えるってことはなかなかない
自然にはほとんど生まれないほど珍しいことなんですね
ですから 正思惟の場合は
わざとネッカンマ 欲に惹かれることではなくて
欲から離れることについて考えなくてはならないということ
だからそれはすごい努力しなくちゃ生まれるものじゃないんですね
いわゆる今まで私はやっていたこういう悪いことはこれからやりませんとかね
どのようにして自分の欲を捨てるかとかね
欲を捨てる実践はどうすればよろしいかとかね
で 考えること 自分が例えば執着して囚われているもの
いろいろありますからね
いろんな美味しい食べ物に囚われているわ
いろんな他のね 欲に対して囚われているんですね
ですから その自分囚われている五欲
五欲から私はこういうものには大変惹かれているんだ
囚われているんだと あるいは例えば音楽には
こういうこういう音楽にはどうしても毎日聴かなくちゃ気が済まないんだとかね
そういう場合はやっぱりそれも欲ですから
じゃあ努力してそれは聴かないようにする
それでもできない場合は
その聴いてる音楽の無常たることやら
無意味であることやらね
苦しみたることやら そういう方向へ考えちゃうんですね
そんなものを聞いたっても
ただ残るのは苦しみだけやと
あるいは精神的なストレスだけやと
さらに欲が増えるだけですよとね
で 音楽を聞いたっても納得いかないんですよと
もっと聞きたくなるんだと
だからこれは人の足を引っ張る
毒されるものだから じゃあ聞かんようにしましょうではないか
そういうふうに無欲の方に思考を働かすということは
この正思惟になっちゃうんですね
それで人々は次に考えるのはやっぱりもう競争することですね
敵を倒すこと 自分の嫌な条件を全部もう片っ端から倒して攻撃して壊して
自分が成功するんじゃないかといわゆる向上心的な考え方ありますね
その向上心っていうのは同じ同義語で競争心なんですね
競争っていうのは相手がなければ競争はないし
ですから相手に対して
攻撃しなくちゃいけないんですね
で それは人間の一般的な思考
向上心っていうのは で
それで心が汚れているんですね
だから それの反対のアウヴィャーパディサンカッパっていうのはなかなか難しい
理解できない 大変なことなんですね
ですから このわざとね
競争するんではないんだとね
まあ自分が向上して向上していくっていうことは
やっぱり自分の精神的な状態はさらに悪くなるだけですよと
偉くならなくちゃ 偉くならなくちゃっていうのは
やっぱり自分心の中に持っているこの高慢というか
高慢というのは何かこの空っぽの心は空っぽなんですね
内容はないんですね だから中の虚しさ
中は精神的な空であることを隠すために一生懸命向上心作って
その風船のようにそれ膨らましちゃうんですね
だから風船というのは大きくなればなるほど
中は空っぽ 空っぽの中が大きくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 人は向上心を持って頑張って成長というものを成長すればするほど,もう何も中身のないむなしい人間になってしまうんです
何もできなくなっちゃうんですね
だから偉くなればなるほど
人の自由がなくなるしね
自分で善悪判断はすることはできなくなるし
ただの操る人間になってしまっちゃうんですね
最後には自分で自由で喋ることさえできなくなる
寝ることさえもできなくなっちゃうんですね
随分偉くなってしまったら
ですから この向上心というのは
この人間物事をわかってないんだから
そういうふうに考えてるんであって
で それでは人間は向上するわけじゃないんで
単なる心の中にあるこの風船が虚しい
空っぽなね 中身のない自分の心が膨らむだけ
大きく見えるんだけど
何もないと 虚しささらに大きいんだと
ですから 逆なことを考えるということ
この間 土曜日かな このなんか女性の年取ってが年上の方 NHK
の心の時代で出てきて
随分いいことをいっぱい言いましたけどね
なんとかお寺のお人なんですけど
この彼女さんがね なんか質問して
だからそういうふうに考えた人々はやっぱり向上していくんですねと言うの
そしたら彼女はいきなり「いい向上心はよくないんだ」と
なんで偉くならなくちゃいけないんですか？そうじゃなくて
人間は一番最低なレベルにいた方が正しいんだと
それで安定するんだと
で 結構仏教のことを理解している人でしたけど
言ってることはほとんどまあすごく
まあ女性だからということもありましてね
やっぱり具体的で 人間のね
本当に心にこれ効くか効かないかとね
役に立つか立たないかという立場で喋ってましたからね
宗派とかそういうふうにあんまりもう全然わからなかったんですけど
あれ 自分というものは自我をね
どんどん膨張するんじゃなくて
それはどんどん一番低いところへ
低いところに持っていって
もう最後に自分が何もないという状態になったところで
そこは仏の心だと まあそこはまあ一応仏教的な考え方なんですね
で あの だからこのアウヴィャーパダってものは
まあ他人を倒す 他人と競争するという考え方というのは
誰でも持っていて 上へ行きたいというね
上へ行きたくなるのは今不安だからなんですね
今むなしいんだからなんですね
同じ道へ行けば行くほどむなしさが増してしまっちゃうんです
戦う相手が大きくなってしまうしね
それアウヴィャーパディサンカッパだ
ヴィャーパダというのは怒りであってね
怒りに基づいて考える
アウヴィャーパディサンカッパっていうのは慈悲に基づいて考える
だから慈悲を実行する人は
やっぱり高慢があれば慈悲ができなくなるんですね
自分が何者でもない場合は
いつでも人のことを親切に考えることはできるんですね
実際に行動を起こす時でも
まあ人にやってあげなくちゃいけないことっていうのは
いとも簡単にできるのは自我がない時なんですね
自分が偉いとかなんとかとか思ったら
もう自分がこういうこういうものだと
そういうふうに肩書きで考えるようになってしまえば
自分には自由に行動できなくなるんですね
ですから自分が何者でもないんだと
何の立場もないんだという状態でいると
で 人のためになること何でもできるんです
ですからアウギャーパドサンカッパというのは
そういうふうな方向へ考えること
で アヴィヒンサーサンカッパっていうのもことまた同じことなんですね
だから怒りの考え方を二種類に分けてるんですね
アウギャーパドのギャーパドっていうのは強力な怒りで
アヴィヒンサーっていうのはそれほど力強くない怒りに考えた方がいいんですね
だからギャーパドっていうのは
強烈に相手と戦いたい
もうという気持ちなんですね
いわゆる負けず嫌いで
もう徹底的に攻撃して戦って前を見て歩くと
それはギャーパド そちらの反対がアウギャーパドというんですね
そこでヴィヒンサーっていうのは
やっぱりそれほど強力じゃないんだけど
もう心の中でやっぱりまあこの邪魔者さえなければいいんじゃないかっていうふうなような考え方はあるんですね
ですから 普通の怒りの考え方はヴィヒンサーサンカッパ
そちらの反対の考え方はアヴィヒンサーサンカッパ
だから人間というのは
例えば自分何かやってると
自分の希望通りにいかないと
いろいろ計画通りにいかないと気持ちは良くないんですね
落ち着かない なんでこうなったんですかとかね
で 文句は言う その場合はヴィヒンサーサンカッパ
そういう物事希望通りにいかない
計画通りにいかないという時でも
まあそんなもんですからいいんじゃないかと落ち着ける
落ち着ける考え方がアヴィヒンサーサンカッパなんですね
それでギャーパドの場合はそうじゃなくて
それではとんでもないんだと
けしからんだと 計画通りにとにかくやらなくちゃいけないと
とにかく攻撃的で 邪魔者は全部消して自分のことを実行しようとする場合はすごい力強いんだよね
考え方が それはギャーパド
ですから ただ怒りのレベルを 2つに分けてるだけ
とにかくこれで考え方なんですね
人々は考えているんだから
それだったら正しいことを考えなくちゃいけない
それは出世的な考え方と
あのギャーパドなんでしたっけ
無私ですかね 無私と無害
で こちらの説明はこの
でもギャーパドっていうのは強い怒りだとこの他のところでは説明しているんです
普通の怒りよりはすごい怒りだと
だからもうどちらどっちかと私もわからないんです
実はこのテキストによらないで
普通の経典とかのところにある注として説明しましたけど
このテキストにあるのは私が言った言葉の逆なんですけどね
どっちでもいいんです
で 次に正語 正しい言葉
それから正業という正しい行い
それから正命っていうのは正しい生活ですね
仕事とか生き方 正精進というのはいいことに努力すること
そこでいいことに努力すると言ったっても
仏教はそこで決まりがあるんですね
単なる努力は認めないんですね
心を清らかにするために努力だけ認めているんですね
心の汚れをなくすための努力だけ認めているんですね
他の努力は認めてないんです
だから正精進と言ったっても
何でも精進というわけにはならないんですね
金儲かるために精進しているんだけど
それは正精進にはならないんです
それはもうただの精進であり
正精進にならないんですね
自分の性格的な弱み 悪いところを直そうという努力だけは正精進なんですね
それは自分持っている徳を完成にしましょうとという完成になることを目指して頑張ることがまた正精進なんですね
決まりがあるんです 正念というのは
四念処経で出てくる四念ですね
で 正定っていうのはサマーディであります
それで悪い方には邪見があるんですね
で なんでこちら邪見入れたんですかというと
やっぱり邪見という心所があるんですね
ディッティという 見というね
智慧の反対の立場は見というんですね
見というのは何も意見
いろんな意見 立場 概念持っていることで
で 智慧っていうのは何も概念も何も持ってないんですね
ですから邪見という働きはあります
ありますので それはここに入ってるんですね
それで邪思ですか それまたあるんですね
それ一般的に人々は欲に基づいて考えるか
怒りに基づいて考えるか
どっちかですから 邪思もあるんですね
これ心所としては正思
それ正思であろうか 邪思であろうか
全部陣に入っちゃうんですね
陣ということで 言葉を持って考えることに入っちゃうんです
そこで邪精進もあります
精進というのはヴィリヤという心所ですね
精進という心所があるんですね
それはいいことに精進すると正精進であって
悪いことに精進すると邪精進になっちゃうんですね
それから邪の定もありますね
サマーディもあります
ミッチャー・サマーディ
ミッチャー・サマーディっていうのは悪いことに自分が統一していることなんですね
心がすごい統一して落ち着いて
集中してやるっていうこと
それから悪いことにしたっても
やっぱりそれなりのすごい集中しなきゃできないし
悪いことには簡単に集中できるんですね
なぜならば心所が揃ってるんで
修行しなくてもいいんですね
なんでサマーディが上がらないかというと
サマーディを作るために必要な善心所が育ててないんですね
全然育てたことがないし
だから土台ができてないんですね
貪瞋痴の心所がもうかなり長い間働いてはったりで
かなり強烈なんですね
心に 強烈だから統一性
定を作ろうと思ったらとても簡単にできるんです
でも悪い方向に だから悪いものだったら
人は我を忘れて一体感になって悪いことをするんですね
でもいいことはそんな簡単にはできない
大変苦労しなくちゃいけない
必要なものは何もそろってない
だから邪定ですか ミッチャー・サマーディの場合は
ミッチャー・サマーディっていうのはレベル高いロープって大心ではないんだけど
普通の即心ですけどね
で 欲界の心なんですが
統一性はあるんです  [終始無声]そういうわけで
人の道というか 人がやっぱり生命がこういうふうにいけてるんだということで
動詞は十二入ってあって
その中で八はいい方向へ
四つは悪い方向に入れてるんですね
この悪い四つはどうしても頑張ってやってはいけないことで
避けるべきことで 正しいやつは必ず修行しなくちゃいけないということになっているんです
それからあの百十三ページに
あの 十八書いてるところでインドラ
二十二のインドラがあるんですね
インディは まあ根としてね
こちらで訳していますが
違うことがあるはずなんですね
ムーラもインディです
本ですから インディの場合は根という意味じゃないんですね
インディっていうのはなんかこの
まあ何かを仕事をするときの
この 例えば会社なんかいろいろ窓口がありますね
なんとかの窓口 なんとかの窓
例えば区役所なんかに行けば
そのその仕事によってそのその窓口がありますね
十三番に行ってくださいとか
これはじゃあ六番に行ってくださいとかね
言われるでしょうに そういうふうな
この働きする窓口という意味で
大変大事なところなんですね
インディっていうのは
だから区役所に例えてみてください
人間一つの区役所のようなもので
だからあの結婚届に来ましたよと言ったら
それはだから何々窓口に行ってくださいと
税金を納めるために じゃあこういう窓口に行ってください
福祉関係で来たんですと言ったら
それでまたそれなりの窓口がありまして
全部まとめたところで区役所なんですね
一つだけ区役所になるわけじゃないんですね
そういうふうに人間というのは
そういうふうにいろいろ働き
窓口がありますということでインディというんですね
そこでこの意味が分かります
この十二 二十二は何ですかと見ると意味が分かります
チャックインディアンソーティンディアンガーナジウハーカーインディアン
チャックソータガーナジウハーカーヤ
いわゆる日本語で言えば何でしたっけ？眼耳鼻舌身という五つありますね
その五つはやっぱり認識するためにね
ものを知るために必要な窓口五つなんですね
[笑い]例えば物の形だったら
それは一番目のチャックという窓口に行ってくださいってことになるんですね
物の形耳に触れても分かりませんだからね
そちらの仕事じゃないんですね
それは物の形を受け取るのは目の仕事で
ですから目は一つの窓口なんですね
音だったら それは口に入ったっても全然意味がないんですね
だから音だったら窓口は耳で決まってるんですね
音の仕事だったら耳で処理するんだと
味だったら舌でその仕事をするし
香りだったら鼻でその仕事をするし
他の触れるものだったら体っていう窓口でそういうことをやってくれるんですね
ですから そこで五つの認識の窓口なんですね
それからの窓口はちょっとわからないんですけどね
一応働きとして言ってるんですね
場所ではないんだけど
例えばイッティンドリヤ
プリシンドリヤ それは日本語で女根
男根と書いてますけど
やっぱりこんなよりも他の言葉あった方がいいと思いますけど
で 生命の体は女性の体にするか男性の体にするかという働きやってるんですね
ある物質的なエネルギーが働いてるんですね
ですから その血のどこかということはちょっと言いにくいんですけどね
まあ遺伝からは言いやすいんですけどね
遺伝の中には女性か男性かもうきちんと決まってますからね
ですから 例えばこの性別する遺伝だと決めてしまえば
それでも構いません それで
だから同じご飯 男の人と女の人が食べても
だからといって体が同じくなること全然同じくはならないんですね
年間同じご飯二人で分けて食べていたんだと
それで二人とも同じ体になるかというと
そうならないんですね
年同じご飯食べようが
四年同じご飯食べようが
そのその食べ物は それは女性の細胞に作るか
男性の細胞にするかということは体の中で決めちゃうんですね
その決める働きはこのイッティンドリヤ
プリシンドリヤという言葉を二つに入れているんですね
次にジーヴィティンドリヤ
ジーヴィティンドリヤっていうのは
この体の生命維持する働きなんですね
それは細胞 一個一個にも入ってるんですね
やっぱり命を維持しなくちゃいけないんだと
といっても どこまで維持できるかっていうことはまた決まってはいますけど
だから DNA の働きを見ると
DNA 自体にはそれほど長生きできません
で ただのね アミノ酸でできてるんだから
ちょっとしたことでも壊れちゃうんですね
で 壊れちゃうんだけど
DNA っていうのはすっごい長生きしたい
死にたくはないんですね
そこでいつでも自分の新しいコピーを作るんですね
細胞分裂というのはそういうことで
一つの細胞が死にかけてくると
それでコピー二つ作って置いておくんですね
作られたコピーはまだできたばっかりだから
ある時間は生き延びるんですね
それでも寿命になってくると
またコピーして作って置いておく
ですから  DNA が自分が生き続けているんだという錯覚をしているんですね
だから人は子供を作るのはそういうわけなんですね
自分が死にたくはないんですね
自分といっても DNA が死にたくはないんですね
そこで体が死んじゃいますから
コピーを外で作っておいて置くんですね
で コピーと作って体から外へ出して
別室に育ててもらう そこで死にかけてる DNA がその新しい DNA のコピーを一生懸命育ててあげちゃうんですね
そこで自分がご褒美として何ももらえません
死ぬだけ 新しい DNA にやられる可能性もあります
裏切れる可能性もあります
せっかく育てた なぜ裏切るか
それも DNA の働きでね
もうあんた用がないんだと
だから私のこれから私の世界だとと思ってるんだけど
それも同じ運命で もう古くなっていっちゃいますから
また自分の体からまた新しいコピーを作って外へ出しちゃうという
それで人間はね 人間ではなくて
生命がいつでも子孫を残すということは
そういうことで 単なるこの DNA は残しておこうと
DNA を残しておこうと思ったら DNA を残すかって
それじゃなくてコピーばっかり作ってるんですね
だからそういう働きがとにかくあるんですね
生命には それはこの命という言葉で理解していても構いませんし
生きているという言葉で理解していても構いませんし
で それは身